DemoBank is a fictitious banking institution
with a rather ordinary mobile application.
A year ago they decided to embark
on a modernization journey
and get more innovative with a microservices-based architecture.
The purpose of this was to allow their developers
to rapidly deliver new features to the market.
The first such new feature was a virtual assistant,
which uses public cloud services
including artificial intelligence, weather, and traffic
to help their clients with directions to the closest no-fee ATM
or updates to branch hours based on weather events.
The application update was a huge market success
and DemoBank was able to gain market share.
They were able to extend their application architecture to multicloud,
while maintaining their compliance,
thanks to the IBM Cloud Pak for Multicloud Management.
Let's dig a little bit more into how they did that
and how they came to that decision.
DemoBank has been an industry leader for a long time
but has recently seen consistent declines in market share.
While a new competitor, AnyBank,
has attracted a lot of DemoBank's existing,
and future, customers.
A strong package of online services,
including banking anywhere
and mobile banking features,
has driven the competitor's success.
And Amy, DemoBank's CIO,
is under the gun to deliver competing services
that will help gain, and retain, customers.
Amy has outlined a new suite of online features
for the development team to build
in order to compete, including a virtual assistant,
mobile check depositing,
and face ID recognition for login.
DemoBank's CIO knows that developing and deploying these new features
using cloud-native architecture
is the best way to compete and continue to innovate
by boosting cross-application reuse of services.
The first step is for DemoBank to modernize
some of its existing application components
and move them to a public cloud.
And while this migration is taking place,
they must continue to keep backend data,
such as account numbers and other sensitive data,
on-premises in their data center
and ensure that they can manage the whole environment
efficiently and securely.
Innovation is the key to winning
and building cloud-native,
while running workloads in a hybrid environment,
offers the speed to market that
DemoBank needs to stay competitive.
But modernization, of course, comes with risk,
especially in the financial industry.
Policy enforcement is critical
with so much sensitive data
and security breaches are always a threat.
DemoBank must ensure its new IT environment
is completely secure and in full compliance
with both its industry regulations
and its enterprise policies.
If any of this is compromised,
it could mean millions of dollars lost
and a tarnished brand image.
Security, governance, and compliance
will be extremely important
over the course of DemoBank's development project
and will continue to be so
once the applications are deployed to production.
Let's take a look at the perspective of Amy, the CIO,
as the decision was made to go forward with this project.
In the pitch meeting,
DemoBank's chief information security officer says,
"Hold on. Remember when FailedBank
tried to do something in public cloud
and exposed sensitive data?
They almost went out of business
from the fines and loss of customers."
DemoBank CEO's responded,
"This is true, but we can't afford to remain idle.
We need to find a way that we can both
embrace new technology and new routes to market
while staying on top of compliance and risk."
As the CIO,
Amy has to think about what it means to her IT operations team
and her SRE teams.
The operations manager, or SREs,
need security and governments within their private
and public clouds.
The project is underway.
It's up to DemoBank's SRE team to ensure
that the enterprises policies are enforced
and compliance requirements are being met
across all cloud and on-premises resources.
The developers deliver the first release
and it is deployed to production.
At first glance, everything looks green
and everything looks good in the environment.
When they dig a little bit deeper,
they notice a glaring security problem
that could affect the integrity of their compliance.
The Kubernetes network security policy
on the public cloud services
is not set the same as it is on-premises
in their production environment.
At this point, there's no automated function
to predict or to remediate that problem.
DemoBank now has a gap in its compliance status
and customer data may be at risk.
Without a proactive way to monitor their multicloud environment,
DemoBank can't effectively know
the health of the environment,
nor have a way to remediate any incidents that could  arise
as they move applications across clouds.
When DemoBank adopted
the IBM Cloud Pak for Multicloud Management,
they leveraged security policies to enforce
the network security settings for their production environments.
Even when a developer changed the setting
to a noncompliant setting,
the policy engine automatically fixed it
and notified central IT.
Once they adopted the Cloud Pak
as a single control plane for their multicloud applications,
the whole C-suite for DemoBank
could now sleep better at night,
development teams could develop more securely,
operations teams could manage more securely,
- all while keeping up with the breakneck pace of innovation.
In this scenario,
you've seen how the fictitious bank, DemoBank,
was able to drive innovation
while maintaining security
by using the IBM Cloud Pak for Multicloud Management
as their control plane for multicloud resources.
Thank you for watching this video.
To learn more, check out the next video in the series
where you can learn how the IBM Cloud Pak for Multicloud Management
can help you with all of your multicloud
governance, risk, and security needs.